[Music]
the electrifying change is hitting the
EDM market thanks to the new Mitsubishi
mV series wire EDM machines with
game-changing all-encompassing
engineering improvements many of which
are industry firsts these machines
deliver productivity and performance
like never before at Mitsubishi we are
always looking to improve we always find
it to within ourselves to compare and
make things better from our previous
generation
so with the new MV series we look to
some of the items from the previous
generation what we can put in and make
it better for our customers the machine
construction itself offers significant
improvements on the MV series with the T
casting you have both the X and y axes
mounted directly to a set of ways on
that base casting so the table moves
right and left on that set of ways the
column moves in and out in the y axis on
that separate centre ways this style of
direct access mounting removes the
squareness and repeatability issues that
come with stacked table design providing
higher rigidity and smoother movement
for more reliable and precise cutting
the MV 1200 machines are also twice as
heavy as previous models and offer a
hardened stainless steel table and
larger travel size without a significant
increase in machine footprint for larger
submerged cutting capabilities
Mitsubishi EDM revolutionizes the
industry with the MVS new cylindrical
drive technology the round magnetic
shaft of the linear shaft motor creates
a 360 degree magnetic flux for a
revolutionary no contact design one of
the negatives on a flat plate system is
obviously it's the magnets are rather
large it takes special construction in
the machine casting in order to mount
this thing but with a linear shaft
design we've actually taken those
permanent bag
and turned them into like little buttons
and lined them up and to end inside of a
stainless steel tube so now we've got a
shaft that basically replaces the ball
screw and when you put the energy
through that that pulls itself along
from magnetic field the magnetic field
the new design prevents any other issues
associated with traditional linear drive
systems which trap heat behind the iron
backplate on the magnetic mount and are
susceptible to metallic shop dust
interference other advantages of the
cylindrical drive motor include higher
speed precision no lubrication or
adjustments simple setup reduce noise no
cogging and the ability to use
commercially available servo drivers and
by eliminating ball screws we eliminate
wear backlash and pitch error
compensation and thus the need for
eventual replacement and the downtime it
creates the new MV servo control system
uses a fiber optic optical drive system
with four times the communication speed
for improved reaction time and accuracy
the advanced plus
uses an optical drive system so instead
of having hard wires running through
everything it's all running on fiber
optics the digital matrix sensor and be
350 type v generator specifically shapes
the pulse to minimize electrode wear and
decrease wire vibration with the
digitally shaped spark and the speed of
the control they've actually been able
to reduce the electrode wear on the wire
thus resulting in the ability to slow
the wire speed down we've seen as much
as a sixty percent reduction in
electrode wear which means a sixty
percent reduction in wire costs that cut
apart with no degradation and part
accuracy or surface energy this combined
with a substantial decrease in power
consumption can lead to a more than
forty percent reduction in overall
operating costs a new auto threader
design delivers improved threading
capabilities upper rollers now travel
with the z-axis creating a constant
distance to the upper guide this allows
for nearly 14 inches of annealed wire
length reducing the wire curl ratio to
10 percent or less improving threading
reliability on tall parts the insertion
method can be set to match the workpiece
shape and operators can now thread
without the jet stream on
to get closer to the workpiece or
machine smaller parts finally a new head
design features a flat plate power
feeder making it easier to index during
operations without the need to open
doors or rotate the carbide or realign
wire shops can realize significant time
savings
solve from the previous version machine
it would probably take a good 10 minutes
or so to index power feeders here you
can do it about a minute per head the MV
series is not just a linear machine it
also provides lower operating costs
reduction in cycle times and up to a 30%
finer finish than previous models
perhaps just as beneficial as the MVS
optimized features is the support that
comes with each machine thanks to a
widespread expert service network
Mitsubishi representatives are always at
the ready providing support well beyond
initial installation
[Music]
you